it's Thursday you know what that means
it's a new video video guess a new video
every Thursday and I am back to my
schedule of videos every Thursday so
tell your friends your family and be
sure to check in now this week's video
was very bare-bones because I'm
preparing to go to Austin for South by
Southwest where I'll be doing live
tweets giveaways secret hangout so if
you're not following me on Twitter at s
Crowder you should be because there's
gonna be a lot going on it'll be a lot
of fun I'll also be doing an in-depth
super video on net neutrality they're
talking about that at South by Southwest
and I'll be covering it and putting it
up here on this channel it's going to be
one of the biggest videos I've done in a
while so stay tuned for that this week I
was actually inspired by my friend Lee
Dorn and how the world works to sort of
give you my personal story of how I
become a conservative know many of you
following me on fox news and on radio
have already heard my sort of history
and to those of you who haven't if you
were following me at s Crowder on
Twitter you would but let me fill you in
I was born in the Detroit area um and
then moved to Montreal Quebec Canada
when I was 3 was raised there throughout
my formative years until about 1718 I
was 17 or 18 not until 17 18 I'd be a
ghost
started working a really young as an
actor I'd done some extra work but my
first substantial role was a voicing a
character and the children's show Arthur
on PBS the little aardvark his best
friend's a bunny and he has a pet dog I
don't know someone was high but I played
the character of the brain that was
Arthur's really smart friend I know it's
out of character that's why they call it
acting and as the paycheck started
coming in um
my dad made me very aware of okay well
you know you're not 18 yet but if you
were this is what would be coming out of
your paycheck at the time it was only
agent fees and union dues but in Quebec
when you're over 18 depending on the
bracket you can be taxed up to 51% and
so my concern
initially stemmed from my selfish nature
as a child well that's my money because
I knew all of the failed auditions the
the failed screen tests the leaving an
audition feeling like I wanted to
swallow a sword and how much work it
took to really get that I think it was
Ronald Reagan who said all great change
starts at the dinner table and and my
dad and my mom made sure that we always
thought critically of these issues they
were granted more conservative but they
never forced that on us and for me with
with my personal beliefs in character
once I started to do the research and
think critically I sort of by default
reverted to conservatism and I've still
never worked a real job for more than a
couple of months and I'm terrible at it
I've always been a small business owner
entrepreneur whether it was performing
it solely stand-up clubs for a couple of
years or doing the acting grind with
auditions and TV roles or now what I'm
doing with videos and and Fox News as a
contributor along with freelance writing
so I had my beliefs I had done my
research and my lifestyle has always
reinforced it but enough about me what's
your story I don't know that's why you
have to tell me whether you're a
conservative or liberal
what brought you to that conclusion and
how do you defend it for now I must go
but I look forward to reading your
comments and I will see you when next
Thursday because the videos are every
Thursday
[Music]